okay I think we're gonna get started our
last panel of the day is on national
security secret and Jeff morally sitting
here beneath me is the wash neder of the
nation who will be moderating the panel
today um we're still waiting for
Christopher Hitchens but he was we were
planning on having him speak last so
we'll just get going and hope that he
comes in the interim I'm gonna introduce
our panelists today welcome all to the
writers watch conference we're gonna be
talking about secrecy an issue very much
in the news perhaps the most interesting
recent development was congressman
George Browns resignation from the House
Intelligence Committee and his comments
surrounding it about the role of secrets
and the government and the frustration
he felt a longer time ago back in 1980
Frank Carlucci then deputy director of
the CIA was speaking to the American Bar
Association about this exact same
subject and about legal constraints on
secrecy and oversight of the
intelligence process and Carlucci told
the Bar Association that the he thought
that the present process the finding
process the process in which covert
actions are approved by a presidential
finding and with the resultant
congressional oversight was the was an
adequate system for overseeing this
country's intelligence operations and he
said he said you just have to trust all
of the people involve the people in
Congress the people in administration
and the president and if you can't trust
them this country is in very deep
trouble indeed I don't know for his
wisdom mr. Carlucci has been appointed
to the Secretary of Defense I don't know
if we would all agree with him that the
country is in very deep trouble indeed
but the process of officials of secrecy
and government is certainly in question
and that's what we want to get to today
first speaker is
Morton Halperin from American Civil
Liberties Union the Center for national
security studies and I'll just get to
him the I think I will be very brief
because I suggest that the next two
speakers will say things that most of
you will find more controversial or
anything
you should leave whatever time there is
for debating that let me just make a few
points on which I think that there is a
consensus on the following points first
that there are there is some information
that the government has a right to keep
secret second that much more information
is kept secret than is in that first
category every study that's been done on
the subject by everybody including all
official studies from within the
government have always concluded that
much more is kept secret then should be
and that that the fact of open then
should be and that that the fact of over
classification and over secrecy is one
of the enemies of effective secrecy as
Justice Stewart said in the Pentagon
Papers case when everything is secret
then nothing is secret and that one
solution to the problem that everybody
agrees should be done is to keep less
secret unfortunately nobody knows how to
have less information made secret and
that is partly because there are a range
of bureaucratic and organizational
reasons why things are kept secret and
often things that kept secret precisely
to keep them from those who would stop
them and we had almost a endless
caricature of that in the iran-contra
hearings take just one of the many
vignettes when Admiral Poindexter was
asked why put it delicately he lied to
the Congress about what Colonel North
was doing he said if you found out what
he was doing you would have stopped them
and we didn't want you to stop him and
so we didn't tell you what he was doing
that is not the sole reason for secrecy
or even quantitatively the most
important but I think Wow
terribly it is and it is the motive for
secrecy that raises the most serious
constitutional questions in a society
with a First Amendment and a dedication
to participation by the Congress in the
public in these in these issues the
system we now have is I think very much
what one should say about is very much
what Winston Churchill said about
democracy which is that it was the worst
system we had except all the others and
the system we now have basically is one
in which the government is free to try
to keep things secret through a variety
of means and the press is free and
others outside the government are free
to try to learn as much as they can and
with a few narrow exceptions of things
like atomic energy and communications
information were recently free to
publish that information without threat
of criminal penalties now as I say
that's a very untidy system it is one
that does not appeal to anybody who who
believes you should decide what should
be kept secret and keep that secret and
then publish the rest but Brian logits
actually worked reasonably well the
government has occasionally even concede
succeeded in keeping things secret that
ought to be kept secret more often the
press has learned about it and chosen
not to publish it and we have learned
some but not all of that information
which I think the public is entitled to
to participate in public debate there
are some orderly things that could be
done one that the Carter Administration
did the Reagan administration took away
was to put a balancing test into the
classification order to require the
bureaucracy to take account of the
public's right to know as well as the
harm to national security from releasing
information and to make that a part of
the Freedom of Information Act so that
the courts can also balance national
security against the public's right to
know another thing that could be done is
for Congress to use the authority it
gave itself in setting up the House and
Senate intelligence committees to engage
in an orderly process through which the
Congress decides despite the objections
of the executive branch
to make information public that
procedure exists it has never been used
to make information public and I think
in what to be used at least occasionally
if not regularly now from the other side
one has to point out that we are in the
process of changing this whole system in
a fundamental way which in my view poses
the most serious threat to the First
Amendment we are now facing in a threat
of extraordinary gravity and that comes
from the indictment of a man named
Samuel Ellen Eliot Morrison for what the
government used shows to quote espionage
and theft Mr Morrison gave information
that he had acquired as a result of and
some degree because of his official
duties to James a British publication
which in turn published it he was
indicted and convicted he's the first
person in the history of the Republic to
be convicted of the crime of giving
information to the press for the purpose
of publishing it and he was convicted
both under the Espionage statutes and
also under the theft statutes which
would extend this not only to national
security information but all information
that the government wants to kept secret
his motions to dismiss the indictment
failed he was convicted the case is now
on appeal it's been argued in the court
of appeals and we're awaiting a decision
of the Court of Appeals if that
conviction is sustained at the court of
appeals level and then by the Supreme
Court we will have an official secrets
act which will make us wish that we had
the British system it basically will
permit the government to label any
information as secret whether on
national security grounds or in any
other grounds and it will then make it a
crime for a government official to give
it to a report or anybody else for the
report or any other private citizen to
receive it to transmit it to anybody
else and that there will be no defense
relating to whether the information had
previously been public there will be no
defense relating to the motive of the
decision and the government's burden of
proof as to what injury would result
will be so tenuous that it would be
extraordinarily difficult if not in
possible to ever mount that defense so I
think that those of us who think there
would it be more debate and more public
information on national security ought
to understand that where we are in fact
facing is the grave danger that there
will be far less our second speaker will
be David Holladay
special assistant to the chairman of the
Senate Intelligence Committee well I
thank my friend Mort Halpert telling me
two things that that I that I enjoyed
one was that anyone from the ACI a cou
would say that they were going to be
brief because someone later was going to
be controversial that's so that's a
delightful statement and the other for
saying that there are some things that
should be kept secret well I agree more
with you on that I'm not sure it's quite
as universally held as you may as you
may think that it is the comments that I
want to make I'm gonna bracket by a
couple of statements one is that anyone
who is looking for justification to
publicize national security information
will find it conversely anybody who is
looking for justification not to publish
national security information will find
that too very seldom are these things
ever black and white there's always good
arguments very cogent arguments on both
sides about why this should be done and
why this should not be done the other
bracket I will give you is that
responsibility for maintaining a free
society cannot be lifted from the
shoulders of any member of that society
now in between I'll point out a couple
of things I think from my point of view
I am not nearly as concerned about
certain secrets that end up being
published either in the in the media or
privately through books or in in other
fashions I am not nearly as concerned
for example about the articles that
appeared dealing with covert actions
that the United States may or may not
find itself engaged in those are the
things that usually from the media
standpoint end up
in the press more often than most other
activities of the intelligence community
as I'm sure as most of you know covert
actions are an exceedingly small part of
what the intelligence community does and
what it's about but those are the things
which end up most titillating the public
and most sought after by by journalists
is what is the United States doing in
the covert action area what will they do
what have they done and did they do it
right when they did it I am not nearly
as concerned about that frankly although
I don't think it's a good idea and I
certainly have not got to help anybody
attain it I think that if every covert
action the United States was involved in
was made public tomorrow morning this
nation would survive it would not be as
devastating a blow as most are a great
many people particularly an intelligence
community would think that it would be
again I don't I don't don't recommend it
and and I'm not gonna help anybody get
there but but that does not concern me
nearly as much as areas such as for
example collection sources and Midlands
intelligence collection how do we do
that where do we do that under what
circumstances do we do that those things
I think are very important to a lesser
extent but also very important is
analysis what does the American
intelligence community think about any
given subject or a given country or a
given leader those kinds of things to me
are far more important as far as the
nation is concerned then our covert
actions and whether or not we are are
not engaged in those it is much more of
a concern to me that the washington post
runs stories on the Ivy bells operation
for example then it is that Bob Woodward
runs a story on whether or not there is
a Libyan covert action operation as as
they did a couple of years ago
collection and analysis are far more
important because you're dealing in
those instances with the nation's eyes
and ears and the nation cannot be
blinded it cannot be deaf in this world
which is increasingly small increasingly
interdependent where it is increasingly
more important
that the decision-makers in this in this
government than in this country have
available to them the best possible
information about the intentions and the
actions of other governments and other
people's I have had over the course of
the three or four years that I've been
involved with the Senate Intelligence
Committee
I've had one dubious honor that I
probably would have felt better to have
to have passed but didn't have the
opportunity and that was to be for a
couple of years first couple of years I
was on the committee what was referred
to as the spokesman for the intelligence
community committee that is that
whenever the press had an inquiry it
came to me and I was supposed to tell
them either yes or no mostly no the man
who went senator Boren who might who I
worked for became a designee on the
committee I went to the committee to
serve as his designee to follow his
interests on the committee but also to
serve as all designee must on the Senate
Intelligence Committee a function for
the committee as a whole
senator Duren Berger at the time was
just coming in as chairman of the
committee and he came to me and he said
I noticed that you have been involved in
the press a time or two and your
checkered career and I would like you to
be the spokesman for the Senate
Intelligence Committee and let me tell
you a couple of things about it it's not
gonna be very hard first of all we never
ever get in the press but nobody ever
says anything about what we do and it
won't take up very much of your time
well I swallowed that I thought off on
that and I said sure senator I'd be
happy to to do that and it ended up
taking all of my time everybody was in
the press all of the time and we didn't
get anything done and answered the
telephone for about two years that has
changed somewhat in under the tenure of
senators Boren and in Cohen and that is
not to meant to be you know would not
anyone want anyone to take that as being
a derogatory slap at senator during
burger senator during burger and Senator
Leahy when they were the chairman and
vice chairman of the committee operated
on a somewhat different basis but they
were no less since
about what they did and what they were
trying to do than the current chairman
and vice-chairman view senator Durand
burger had the idea and I think at the
time that he espoused it to me it was a
perfectly reasonable idea and I think
one that still is reasonable that there
are aspects of the intelligence business
the intelligence community that can be
made more public than they have been
made in the past it is possible to talk
to the public more about what the
intelligence is probably more important
or equally as important what
intelligence is not what this country
does from time to time in the
intelligence field what the intelligence
community is there are certain aspects
of that that I think could be talked
about publicly and I believe that he
thought could be talked about publicly
too unfortunately as time went on and as
there came to be more and more of a
conflict between senator Durand burger
and then directors of the Central
Intelligence Agency bill Casey you know
that sort of thing kind of got lost in
the in the noise and the rhetoric that
was going on over those two years but
the basic idea was a good one and I
think that senator Durand burger was
very sincere in wanting to do that I
still think it's possible to do and I
think senator Boren believes that it's
possible to be more open in the matters
coming before the committee that has
generally been accepted in the past we
have held a couple of open hearings
we're going to hold a couple of more in
the next week or two dealing with
oversight legislation that is now
pending before the committee the one
other other point that I would want to
cover and I'm gonna leave the the
Morrison case to my friend Mike McDonald
here I'm sure he has some stock some
strong feelings about it and that is the
responsibility in what I was talking
about earlier I have had over the course
of the last three or four years a number
of times
reporters primarily reporters who will
say to me something of the following it
is not anything I can find out I can
print or I can broadcast
it is not my responsibility to keep the
new government secrets it's your
responsibility and if you can't do that
then that's not my fault so if I find it
out I'm gonna go with it now I hasten to
say that I would not ascribe that
philosophy to a majority of the
reporters that I have dealt with over
the course of the last three or four
years but a significant number a
surprising number and some surprising
individuals who have said that to me or
words to that effect over the course of
these of these three or four years and
that is why I put in the line that I did
at the beginning that responsibility for
maintaining a free society cannot be
lifted from the shoulders of any member
of that society the media itself and
writers themselves whether they're in
the media or whether we're dealing with
private writers who freelance or or
private writers have a responsibility to
police themselves to a degree where
national security matters are concerned
it's a very difficult job one of the
things more it says is absolutely true
and that is that there is more kept
secrets than should be or needs to be
kept secret but the the test is who
makes that decision who decides what is
to be kept secret and what is not and as
he says the process of doing that is a
very messy one because it involves the
government it involves the media it
involves the courts it involves the
system it is the system itself that is
going to make the ultimate judgment as
to what should be kept secret and what
should not many of the reasons he gives
on classification and so forth are
absolutely correct there are things that
the committee has dealt with and has
tried to deal with over the course of
several years
because things are kept oftentimes
classified for no other reason than for
a political a political one and that is
that is not right
however it does take responsibility on
all parts it takes the responsibility in
the oversight Committees of the Congress
itself of members of the intelligence
community of the administration and of
the media everyone must share in that
response
ability no one can take the attitude
that it is not their responsibility
we're national security is concerned and
we can get into a lot more discussion
about that a little later if you get you
so desire but I think I'll stop the
early Mike takes on the Morrison kick
our third speaker will be Michael poppy
McDonald from the Washington legal
family and I should welcome you into the
controversial part of the program now
I'd like to thank writers watch and
particularly Emily sac for inviting me
to participate in the panel discussion
borrowing a phrase that was made as
somewhat popular in the waning days of
his ill-fated confirmation fight should
say that I harbor no illusions about
changing any minds this afternoon
particularly among writers and
journalists who don't seem to want to
hear about balancing in the First
Amendment context I think by and large
at the J schools that they attend they
the professor's seem to dwell
disproportionately on the somewhat
literal view of the First Amendment
prepared by Justice black that is that
the framers that did all the balancing
for us when they declared that Congress
shall make no law abridging freedom of
speech or of the press yet one need not
be a museum disciple of original intent
to recognize that such absence of such
an absolute position has never commanded
a majority on the Supreme Court and I
would I would concur with the professor
Leonard Levy's remarks that it is an
hallucination of sentiment that ignores
history to assume that that's what the
framers had in mind when they adopted
the First Amendment indeed we all know
that the constitutional convention
itself was shrouded in secrecy and I
wonder how whether we would be here
today as a nation with the document that
had survived 200 years if the drafts had
been routinely circulated in the popular
press of the day with two and a half
million employees having access to
classified government information I
think it's fair to say that leaks to the
press are always going to be a
and given the press's proclivity to
publish secrets regardless of the
consequences and I'd like to underline
that regardless of the consequences
we will doubtless continue to see cases
arise in which courts are forced to
engage in a balancing of interests
between the First Amendment and national
security now let me say of course I
believe that the threat that the press
plays an extremely important role in
informing society about the democratic
process and I certainly believe that the
freedom to publish relevant information
about the activities of our government
is central to the protection afforded
First Amendment and is fully justified
in principle and yet there are other
interests at stake our society has a
clear need to protect certain types of
Defense information and I would throw
the question on the table should the
press be entitled to disregard this need
to protect national security information
once it has managed to get a hold of
such sensitive information should
unelected and unaccountable members of
the press be the ones weighing the
official secrets as the titles of the
title of today's panel hazard in my view
the short answer to those questions is
no the journalists are citizens the
journalists have the same obligation as
others to obey the law and they have the
same obligation that we all do to trust
in the elected representatives of our
government to operate properly we
operate in a representative system of
government I think the distinction is is
all too often lost that the framers were
did not design a pure democracy in which
everyone has an equal vote and and in
which one public public employee of the
government may take it upon himself to
become the nation's conscience and
leaked information to a journalist who
again may take it upon himself to become
the nation's conscience and to release
that information far and wide
unfortunately it seems in recent years
we have grown up many and many anomalies
have grown up in the law and it's
somewhat curious that if a Department of
Energy employee were to reveal closely
held trade secrets or oil oil
exploration data to a private company
like say Mobil Oil now that employee
could find himself automatically
discharged and soon sitting behind bars
along with mobiles executives but with
some important qualifications I'll come
to in a minute qualifications that have
largely come about because the Reagan
administration came to town in 1981 with
an explicit goal to cut down on leaks an
employee of the Defense Department who
leaks classified information to a member
of the press is probably not going to
face criminal action nor will member of
the press who publishes that information
similarly a government employee who is
paid to steal secrets and pass them to a
foreign government well if he is caught
be subject to a vigorous prosecution I
think it's safe to say without any de
murals from the members of the press but
if a reporter obtains official secrets
and publishes them to everyone who reads
his newspaper and the KGB have been
known to walk across the street from
their embassy and drop as a quarter in
the machine and pick up a copy of The
Washington Post suddenly the espionage
laws are deemed totally inapplicable to
the situation at hand as I said the
situation has changed somewhat during
the past few years yet the press is
receiving and is continuing to weigh
secrets and is publishing leaks with the
same or greater frequency than it ever
did they go back to something that Mort
Halperin said at the at the start of the
program I'd like to think that we can
all agree that technical information
about cryptograph cryptographic
techniques intelligence gas gathering
operations and sources the designs of
secret weapon systems and so on are
appropriate subjects for prohibition on
press disclosure I'd like to think that
but unfortunately I can't seems that
three years ago in December of 1984 we
saw the Washington Post run a story on a
super-secret sig int satellite that the
space shuttle Discovery was about to
carry into orbit the story described the
weight and configuration of the
satellite it listed its purpose it
detailed the orbit of the satellite and
had even a published information
regarding the sort of information that
that the American government was hoping
to pick up from Soviet missiles this is
all highly technical information now a
half dozen news agencies have the same
story including Aviation Week an honored
personal request from the Secretary of
Defense not to publish if the post did
its defense when someone tells us a
report we are about to publish threatens
national security quote we listen and we
decide what to do I find it somewhat
pathetic to reflect that if the post had
obtained copies of the redskins
superbowl playbook it probably wouldn't
have published them at a some
sportsmanship theory but when national
security is at stake and they're only
too happy to put the material into print
i think the the point to remember well
the point that that story illustrates is
that there is very little consensus on
foreign policy goals between the press
and the government or at least as much
as existed say in the second world war
the quote a good conservative friend pat
buchanan to continue regarding the
washington post is simply a newspaper is
somewhat like regarding Rasputin is
merely a parish priest as an institution
the post is partisan the post staff and
the reporters on the post contains
several partisans who SS reporters and I
think the same is true at the opposite
end of the spectrum for the Washington
Times and I would asked the liberal
members of today's audience to consider
how well they plan to receive leaks
published by the Washington Times to
subvert the domestic or foreign policy
goals of the Cuomo our Gephardt
administration after 1988 but it goes
beyond liberal or conservative although
I think that's a highly animating factor
in a lot of these a lot of the decisions
to publish classified information the
press simply stated has an institutional
interest in breaches of confidence
writers can't seem to understand that
just as they have to maintain the
confidentiality of their news sources so
the government at times has two main the
maintain the confidential
it's I would agree with Morton Halperin
that the government is very much a
contributor to its own to the tooth to
this problem over-classification has
gotten out of hand
out of hand and leaks are coming from
the top I think of John Kennedy's
remarked that the American ship of state
is the only ship that leaks from the top
and I and in the past few months as
we've seen Bob Woodward's book on Vail
with the unauthorized disclosures made
by Bill Casey it can only wring my hands
that's that such things would go on in
this administration but the point to
emphasize is that it doesn't matter if
the government is careless or in an
intentionally or unintentionally stupid
and mishandling information we don't the
law doesn't grant immunity to a thief
who breaks into a house merely because
the owner happened to leave the door
open
I'm only hopeful that in the future two
developments may change this sad state
of affairs one is the United States
versus Morrison that was mentioned
earlier today and the other is changes
in personnel at the Supreme Court I'm
pleased to be able to say that whereas
the American Civil Liberties Union the
law firm of Covington and Burling and
about 30 press groups all filed briefs
trying to get the conviction of Samuel
Morrison overturned at the Fourth
Circuit Court of Appeals that the
Washington Legal Foundation was the only
group to file a brief in support of his
conviction and on the side of the
government I like the way Mort helperin
put it that Sam Morrison merely quote
gave information to the press I think
unspoken was the fact that he was in
some sense perhaps furthering the
people's right to know
you know Samuel Loring Morrison worked
in a vaulted area at the Naval
Intelligence Lab he had a top security
clearance and he was regularly briefed
about his fiduciary obligation to guard
secrets in order to get a job with a
British publishing magazine James when
some classified intelligence documents
and photographs satellite photographs
came across his desk he
took a pair of scissors he cut off the
secret designation on the photos and he
sent them to Jane's editors with notes
intimating that perhaps he'd get a
better job at James he was thinking of
leaving government service the
government picked him up at Kennedy that
was either Kennedy or Dulles
International Airport they questioned
him they found out that he had lied that
that he initially lied about having
released the information and then all of
a sudden we see this full-blown First
Amendment defense come up about Morrison
was really trying to further the
public's right to know I don't buy it I
don't think that the judges of the
Fourth Circuit are going to buy I think
his conviction is going to be sustained
and I wouldn't be surprised if it's
sustained unanimously lastly I think
that the 1988-89 term of the Supreme
Court perhaps not this term is going to
be a watershed year in the area of First
Amendment jurisprudence and about the
ability of the press to publish secrets
at will
the 8687 term of the Supreme Court
marked an end
it was justices Lewis Powell's last term
there were eleven free speech cases and
the government action was invalidated in
seven of the eleven Justice Powell was
anymore in the majority of all eleven
cases of course he's been something of a
swing vote for quite some time
we now have Justice Scalia on the court
and I think Justice Scalia takes a more
common-sense view of the First Amendment
if if as I suspect just a judge Kennedy
is confirmed and if he is more
sympathetic than justice Powell was
through the governmental interest and
claims of national security I think we
can begin to see people like Scalia
taking a more active role in remaking
First Amendment law and if that occurs
and if the proper cases are brought up
there is a case currently pending at the
court evolving prior restraint of the
press which I think would have very
direct and immediate application to the
presses ability to publish secrets and a
Pentagon Papers type situation I think
we may be able to restore some
rationality to this area of the law
through the court
and I'll end here and wait for the
firestorm to erupt our final speaker is
my colleague from the nation Christopher
Hitchens first condolences to all those
who came here thinking that you know
they were gonna get Peter Pringle whose
mighty mighty shoes I've engaged to fill
and who has put us all in his debt by
his writing about the nuclear state and
other aspects of British policy though
he also specializes in the melancholy
distinction possessed by my country
which is being the prototypical home of
the theory and practice of official
secrecy and censorship which is the
subject I've been asked to address today
I have the same vanity as every other
member of this profession which is that
I set some store by my reputation at
least for veracity if not exactly for a
liability and I have a difficulty when
when speaking on this subject especially
in the United States and speaking about
the operations and the theoretical
background of official secrecy in
Britain and the difficulty is simply
stated it's that I can tell often what
I'm talking to American audiences that
they think I must be making at least
some of it up because the merest sketch
of the problems of political journalism
in Britain insofar as they relate to
disclosures have officially held
information do in fact have the Faculty
of rendering the literary efforts of
Joseph Heller and Franz Kafka amateur by
contrast you may have imagined yourself
in a slightly fantastic world listening
to Mr Macdonald a moment ago and hearing
about a mythical American press that
doesn't seem to be the same one as gave
the Reagan administration a completely
free ride on national security at home
and abroad and had to play catch-up to
the evening edition of a rag in Beirut
in order to earn its condemnation from I
think you identified it as your friend
Patrick Jay Buchanan if you think that
sort of allegation about a pretty tame
and domesticated press in the United
States is fantastic you have yet here
the opening periods of my
remarks about Fleet Street I'll start
with an example that's both apt in
itself and apt in the current climate of
glasnost and perestroika a matter of
five weeks ago British government seized
the English edition of the well known
morning newspaper Pravda they seized
this edition of about its distribution
in the United Kingdom because the
provide' contained an article based on
the by now really quite well known
memoirs of mr. Peter Wright former
employee of mi6 by capture I have a
slightly nunc dimittis moment when I
read that I felt rather as I thought
when I saw Regan described as a useful
idiot for the Kremlin on Nightline the
other night I felt I've lived long
enough to see that said and I've lived
long enough to see thatthe censoring
Pravda in the interests of British
national security
this is the moment I think of apotheosis
for those of us who've studied who've
studied study the Official Secrets Act
in operation we already knew that any
American or Canadian could buy and read
spy culture we already knew that though
not every Soviet citizen had that
privileged that the Soviet intelligence
authorities knew what was in it the
Albanian intelligence authorities knew
or was in it the Chinese Hungarian
polish Bulgarian and Czechoslovak
intelligence authorities had already we
already knew that only we were not
supposed to be allowed to read but we
didn't know we wouldn't be allowed to
read what they knew and felt about it
and there's some who don't think that
this final flourish in the application
of the law to national security was
strictly speaking necessary people who
feel that this grace note this coda
could have been spared us but I take the
contrary position I think it is entirely
and predictably in the logic of the
official secret sight and the ideology
that undergirds it that apotheosis
should have been reached how was it
arrived at you'll be aware of the fact
we don't possess a Bill of Rights in
Britain we fact have no rights at all we
only have traditions and though
traditions traditions can be sturdy and
the tradition of English Liberty in my
opinion is a sturdy one and has to be
upheld against such things as official
secrecy it is only a tradition and you
have no right of resort to the courts
against government malfeasance in most
areas this is especially true in the
area of information and a distinguished
British constitutional scholar RHS
Crossman cabinet minister and historian
amended water budgets view of the
English English Constitution as being
that of cabinet government - one of
prime ministerial government where the
Prime Minister was more than premisis
into Paris but was more along the
presidential monarchic au model and in
the course of this study of the
narrowing of British constitutional
structure defined secrecy as the
essential English disease he became an
illustration of his own point when he
attempted to publish his memoirs of
for being a cabinet minister in two
governments and was told by the House of
Lords that there was no right for him to
publish it and there was no right for
the English public to buy or read a book
that detailed the workings of government
as seen by a cabinet minister in fact
that that ruling wasn't set aside by the
House of Lords until long after the
author of the book had died but that
gives an example of the super adjacent
atmosphere in which these things are
discussed there is no right at all there
are there are occasional traditions very
unevenly invoked the supreme symbol of
this want of right and unevenness of
traditions is the is the Official
Secrets Act visual Secrets Act bore and
bears the marks of its birth it was it
was rushed through Parliament at a time
of spy fever in the First World War when
the royal family for example was
changing or its German titles to English
once and repudiating its German
citizenship and there was a tremendous
wave of chauvinism sweeping the country
dachshunds were found disemboweled in
Hyde Park all this kind of thing a law
was passed it said that anyone giving
any kind of aid and comfort of any sort
of so forth to the German branch in the
British royal family was in fact what it
was the other side in this war would
suffer the full penalty of the law
without being told why now this bill has
been promised well it has been promised
by every government elected since this
bill will be repealed since it is on its
own face absurd and unjust but every
incoming government has found it
unrepeatable convenient it is it is
modeled on the dream of any state power
it is a law that permits the government
to do anything and it's thus not above a
tool which is likely to be easily
discarded and it gives me a terrible
free song whenever I do hear American
conservative jurists speaking fondly or
endlessly of this either of this bill as
as amended and enacted or speaking
fondly of the theory of secrecy that
underpins it the central provision
central aspect
the essence of the Official Secrets Act
is its definition of secrecy its
definition of secrecy is somewhat more
extreme than the one what happened
alluded to in his introductory remarks
it doesn't say that the government can
define what his national security or is
in the national interest it says that
the government can define what is a
secret I mean by this to say and here's
the point where I sometimes think people
think I may be romancing the evidence
someone it means that there it is no
defense in a court case brought under
Section five and official secrets so to
prove that the information he printed
was already in the public domain that
doesn't mean it cannot be defined a
secret I used to have to go around for
nearly a month with a toothbrush in my
top pocket about this very point which
is why I remember and was in fact fully
expecting and anticipating going to jail
on it because and how many of you've
been to London but how many is a matter
of interest
well even those of you very soon picture
the skyline may recognise the post
office tower it's the largest structure
on the London skyline because the post
office tower is the center of an axis of
communications technology in Britain it
was ruled to be an official secret in
the course of this trial in which the
future couldn't be mentioned in front of
the jury couldn't be entered in evidence
as existing at all
now the fact that it was it was no
defense for our lawyers to say the
existence of the post office tower
worship is not a secret it is already in
the public domain it was defined for all
purposes of the trial as location one
the island of the the island of the
island of Cyprus was also a republic and
a member of the comity of nations where
several British intelligence listening
stations which you can go to in a
tourist car and drive up to the gates
was defined as location to the island of
Cyprus was ruled to be its existence was
ruled to be an official secret for the
purpose of the trial and that's not
considered absurd because because it is
the government if the government loses
the right to define what is a secret
then it will have to fall back on
defining something that's national
security which would be obviously much
more arbitrary the control therefore
must be and I think in all arguments of
the kind patroller mr. McDonald
inevitably is the government must have
the right
say what is a secret because otherwise
the public domain defense in any
pluralistic democracy will always be
available and if that is allowed then
the law is an ass and that is precisely
what a national security state may not
or dare not permit therefore of course
to be accused under the Official Secrets
Act ISM is axiomatically X hypotheses to
be found guilty or rather to be guilty
it's possible not to be convicted but
that's because the government simply
cannot prosecute everybody who breaks it
since everybody in the practice of
journalism breaks it necessarily every
day collection of information
interestingly is one of the one of the
sturm one of the phrases in the statute
one of the searching for the right word
one of the charges of the statute under
which you may be brought to trial
collection of information is a heading
under which you may be indicted and that
is I think you'll readily see a very
difficult rap for journalists to beat
now the reason why I think it's nothing
to do with national security is that is
this and I have to mention another
anecdote here because of this fact a lot
of British researchers when they're
looking into the history of British
foreign policy and defence policy have
to come to Washington because there are
archives on Britain available to them
here that are closed in the public
record office and one of the British
historians who took this route when
writing about the history of the British
Secret Service was Andrew Boyle in his
book the climate of treason and it was
while researching in the United States
what he was forbidden by law to read in
the United Kingdom that he discovered a
very interesting thing which was that
surrounds a blunt keeper of the Queen's
pictures and honored citizen had been
for the previous 20 years a confessed
KGB agent now
if he had published that in any English
paper two things could have happened to
her probably both of them would first he
would have been charged with breaking
the Official Secrets Act by revealing
the identity of a highly placed KGB
agent who was protected by the British
establishment second Blount could have
sued him and would have sued if a
criminal libel and would certainly have
one aware of this I did print the
missing
both man was scientists in the New
Statesman in order to await developments
and it had the desired effect I did it
because the Official Secrets Act was
being amended in Parliament at the time
and mrs. Thatcher was well known to be
very tender about it and she was
compelled to get up in Parliament and
admit for the first time in 20 years yes
it was to essentially blunt him in the
KGB agent yes a bargain had been struck
with him yes he hadn't been prosecuted
no he hadn't betrayed anyone else they'd
simply been a cover-up and it wasn't to
cover up if you will allow me to say so
that defended British national interest
from the KGB in in revealing that she
had to admit that the new amendments to
the Official Secrets Act would have
protected Blount just as much as the
previous Act had done and he would have
enjoyed government support in bringing a
case of criminal libel I submit that
that is of the same order of absurdity
as the private or example that I began
with and that's why I think the private
example is not a farcical conclusion but
is in the nature of the of the theory
and practice of official secrecy law so
I regard in fact official secrecy among
other things as a negation of the proper
conduct and and supervision of national
security now I noticed that some I'll
close with two anglo-american examples
for the sake of comity and
internationalism the first is the case
of it's another illustration this is a
case of Ed Edward Armero
a great man in our profession and
someone who many of us admire when Ed
Moreau came to London in 1940 and you
know the United States was officially
neutral in the battle against Nazism he
was anxious to try and alert the
American listener to this problem and
found that at every turn when he asked
could he interview bomb victims could he
interview the inhabitants of a civilian
towns on the east coast that had been
shelled from the sea by the Nazis could
he talk to refugees from the
concentration camps were being processed
in the Channel ports at all terms he was
told no that Official Secrets Act did
not permit him to do this all the
broadcasts the famous broadcast that ed
Murrow made that I think may be among
the few examples of journalism altering
the course of history certainly altering
it that much for the better were made in
defiance
of a law that was designed to protect
the national security of the United
Kingdom and that's an irony I think
oughtn't to be lost by practitioners in
the field secondly I can never help but
notice that when when Republican
politicians in this country are caught
out fibbing they tend to reach for a
Churchillian
example and I noticed the other day
notice the other day George Shultz and
Caspar Weinberger saying well as it was
after the big disinformation campaign
when them this was I'm sorry after mr.
Louis after the press had decided not to
take William cases word for everything
as a regrettable period elapsed after
the case of Poindexter disinformation
they said well as Churchill used to say
truth is so important that it needs to
be protected by a bodyguard of lies and
I thought well they've got the bodyguard
of lies bit right but unlike Churchill
they are not seeking to receive the
Third Reich nor they are seeking to
deceive anyone outside the borders of
the United States of America the
bodyguard of lies is directed at their
own people as was evident in that case
and in closing I would say and would
claim to say from experience that you
should never allow yourself to forget
when considering official secrecy in its
analogues that you're the intended
target of official secrecy and those who
doubt it and those who swallow the
patriotic defenses that are made for
this absurd construct are preparing in
their minds and trying to prepare your
minds to become model citizens in a
national security state and that's a
destiny that I think you should reject
while you're lucky enough to be able to
do so thank you
like to thank all our presenting members
here and without wasting any more time
open the floor up to questions from you
about directed to any of the
participants I would just ask that
people identify themselves before they
ask their question David Eisen the
newspaper guild mr. McDonald you took
some umbrage at the Washington Post
statement that it namely the Washington
Post would decide what the Washington
Post would print keeping particularly in
mind your concession about the vast
amount of over-classification
and the leaking at the top who would you
suggest should be the proper body to
decide what the Washington Post should
be able to print the point that I took
the point that I was taking umbrage at
was the fact that the post regularly and
routinely receives stolen classified
government originated information which
the elected officials of this government
and the representatives in the relevant
agencies have determined that the
release of which would be highly
detrimental to the public interest into
the national security I don't know that
any of the editors have over over at the
post have the same degree of expertise
or or overview on the information that
they received to be able to make that
decision I'd like to see that the I'd
like to see the post and do something
out of character and that is listen to
the Department of Defense officials for
once if they tell them that release of
the information would jeopardize
national security so I would leave that
decision back to the elected
representatives and the people in the
relevant agencies with oversight of that
information I do not think that it
should be made by Ben Bradley and his
minions I'm sorry I just don't
yes my name is Ants parent and I'm
freelance writer and I don't want to
sound like 1776 and all that but I can
remember learning in history years and
years ago probably before you were born
that one of the ideas of the Bill of
Rights came before the came from the
reign of William and Mary so I just
wonder if Englishmen have an only
tradition and no rights where did we get
the idea that they came from that reign
good question um in fact we're about to
celebrate next year the 1688 glorious
revolution as it was known what I mean
to say is that there is no there's no
amendment to which you can make a
judicial appeal that says no law can be
made to say this the government for
example can and does send what's called
a D notice around Fleet Street this
notice says if you become aware of the
closest or if you're already aware of it
don't print anything about it now there
is no way of taking the government to
court and saying you mustn't do that if
you see what I mean there can also lead
to complications in Official Secrets Act
because editors seeking to comply can
say of an issue of defense spending for
example would you please tell us what
you don't want us to publish that's been
known to happen now I'd say that's bad
enough though it's what mr. McDonald
regards as a model state of affairs my
last answer um I'd say that was bad
enough but the government on the
Official Secrets Act refuses on the
grounds that if they told them which
bits they didn't wanted to publish
they'd be telling them what the secret
bits so no we're not telling you you've
just got a guess and what people can do
in that circumstance they're going to do
what mr. McDonald I suspect once they do
which is not print anything at all and
go for the Royal Family's outings with
corgis instead and then you have the
model press of a national security state
and then don't complain I mean I think I
will I know I heard you say it's already
done we that but reporters like everyone
else have an obligation to trust in the
elected representatives of the
government I would say that was a very
precise statement of what reporters
don't have and citizens shouldn't have
the obligation to trust the government
this is pure civility I'm across the
Atlantic to get away from this mentality
if there are any more questions
um and I don't think there are we'll
close the session now again thanking our
presenters and just want to remind
everybody that there is a reception for
members of Congress who have written
books at the Mott house which is across
the capitol grounds at 122 Maryland that
will go on from 5:30 to 7:30 this
evening
can you go yes